supervolcanoes are the most violent and
complex class of volcanoes but despite
their destructive capabilities they can
also make way for life renewed around 20
super volcanoes are scattered across the
planet they're usually characterized as
large depressions in the ground called
calderas located above multiple openings
in the Earth's crust in terms of
eruptions super volcanoes explode at a
magnitude of 8 the highest and most
violent classification on the volcanic
explosivity index super volcanoes
undergo a life cycle of three major
stages a surge of trapped magma a super
eruption and a resurgence the first
stage of a super volcanoes life cycle
involves a pocket of magma trapped under
the Earth's crust called a hotspot this
magma reservoir is fed by a pipeline
deep into Earth's molten interior it
grows and builds pressure underground
eventually causing the crust above to be
pushed upward the supervolcano can't be
Flegrei on the west coast of Italy has
pushed the ground up several times over
the past few decades at one point within
a matter of only two years enough magma
accumulated to cause the ground to swell
up to six and a half feet the next stage
of a super volcanoes lifecycle is a
super eruption at this point the
build-up of pressure in a magma
reservoir hits a critical mass and then
explodes sending over 1,000 cubic
kilometers of tephra or ash and rocky
material into the sky
the most recent super eruption occurred
in New Zealand approximately 26,000
years ago the supervolcano
PAH ejected about 1100 cubic kilometers
of tephra into the air enough material
to constitute nearly half a million
Great Pyramids of Giza after a super
eruption a supervolcano undergoes a
stage called resurgence having dispelled
its contents a super volcano's magma
reservoir collapses and forms a caldera
the Yellowstone Caldera in the United
States is currently in resurgence after
a super eruption occurred about 640,000
years ago in the time since fresh water
collected in the caldera to form a lake
plants and wildlife returned to reclaim
the space in some of the world's largest
geothermal features emerged super
volcanoes have created unparalleled
natural beauty all in the wake of some
of the world's most cataclysmic events
[Music]